[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] them
good morning good morning
[Music]
uh more news
in ukraine
[Music]
sergey lavrov can't hold the crowd
the president of ukraine zlinski gets a
standing ovation
from the world hmm
[Music]
i wonder who's on what side of which
history
i wonder i wonder i wonder i wonder it's
a it's a
a day of speeches i guess um we're going
to have the state of the union from the
president of the united states the duly
elected ass-kicking president
joe biden
you know like 8 million votes that's
that's that's pretty good ass kicking
so we're gonna see that tonight state of
the union
uh good morning to all debbie is here
good morning robin is here
christina is here vicky hello
good morning mj she says dm
there must be some um some good stuff
waiting there kathy is here
midas lisa is here
snick is here welcome welcome all
to everyone on the chat
welcome to the show
you know we do the show every single
weekday noon eastern 11 central
youtube twitter twitch tonight is
the
state of the union so tomorrow i'm sure
a portion of our show will be dedicated
to what the act what the president
actually says um today we're gonna
we're gonna because it is trending today
so we're so when we go through the
shitless roundup where we round up all
the tweety tweets and attorney trends we
will
be going through
uh the
state of the union
thread
a bit
uh but there is more and more news
coming out of ukraine
as russia heats up their
their war their aggression their
invasion of a sovereign nation ukraine
the president of ukraine gives a speech
to which he receives a standing ovation
because he's not going to back down he's
not going to give up
they're not just going to give their
country away to a tyrant
not going to happen
um
putin seems to be more and more isolated
here as sergey lavrov gives a speech
to the u.n
and
i'll show you the video but
it seems like even more half the room
stands up and walks out not to give an
ovation to get the hell out of there
good morning mayo
good morning
thank you for joining us here on the
tony michaels podcast
we got some other stuff in the news as
well uh yesterday
um thomas massey
and chip roy and um
andrew clyde
those [ __ ] pieces of garbage
voted
not
to pass the anti-lynch build they are
pro-lynching they are pro-lynching which
is not surprising i mean for a party who
really backs putin and who wants to be
putin's puppets and loves putin loves
his tyrannical ways loves that he goes
in and and takes sovereign nation he he
kills dissidents he kills journalists he
kills
lgbtq community
perfect opportunity for thomas matthew
massey clyde
and chip roy those [ __ ] pieces of
[ __ ] to be pro-lynching i mean why not
why not they're
why not
they mind is [ __ ] well their entire
republican party might as well be
pro-lynching at this point
the humanity the humanity is lost on
these [ __ ] idiots uh nikki haley is
apparently trending the senior senate
gop is trending joe manchin is trending
as long as well as another senator marco
rubio
of course uh end times and he would use
nukes
as trending and you know who that's
about we have to stop vladimir putin now
um this is this is a dire situation
um there is a lot of trouble that is
going to be
where we're headed there's a lot of
[ __ ] trouble ahead
um if we if we do not
make sure that this delusional tyrant
who has access to nuclear weapons
is put under some sort of control um we
see that the invasion of russia
i don't know if talks broke down in
belarus but it seems as if
um russia and again yesterday i i
thought the talks in belarus was
probably a ruse
that's more [ __ ] from vladimir putin
and sergey lavrov which we're going to
show the video of everyone standing up
and walking out on that piece of [ __ ]
as the oligarchs are pressured
as their bank accounts their airplanes
are pressured
as their way of life in foreign
countries are pressured
as the as the russian economy collapses
the ruble
is brought to nothing
we will see more and more
how this plays out
fiona hill
you remember fiona hill
a diplomat who
who testified during the first
impeachment where donald trump withheld
weapons
and funding for weapons from ukraine got
it
in an effort to seek
political damage to is a political
opponent because he knew joe biden would
kick his [ __ ] ass
knew it
there's no [ __ ] secret
donald trump is scared of joe biden has
been always will be that [ __ ] [ __ ]
and tonight i hope joe biden lays into
the republican party no holds barr
this [ __ ] pro-putin [ __ ] he needs to
put an end to this stuff in this country
and draw the line in the sand
that not only the democratic party but
the united states government is not
going to stand for this [ __ ] we've seen
a video yesterday of some [ __ ] fat
clown
from texas
dancing around
in in his little his little trees and
hat
which he should have been wearing a maga
hat and
to be frank with you
taking up with the the russian army
we're gonna probably watch that video
too and
[ __ ] piece of
uh [ __ ] going to be joining us at 9 30 i
believe
uh pacific time his time so 12 30
eastern if you're counting
uh he'll join us for a bit we have a
couple other guests that might be
joining us
um uh hopefully we can get some other
guests on i'm trying to get some folks
who have family in ukraine on the show
or who are on the ground in ukraine on
the show so we will try to see if we can
bring those guests in uh timing is is
key here maybe we'll bring them in for
five 10 15 minutes something of that
nature as we tick along for the show
today which again it's two hours every
single weekday noon eastern 11 central
youtube twitter twitch go tell all your
friends go tell all your family because
we're not going to stop
tomorrow we're going to be talking about
the state of the union i think thursday
we're going to play the the data dump
interview finally
i want to play it as soon as possible
but we have all this russian ukraine
news and then tonight we have the state
of the union
and tomorrow we will talk about that
during the show
the two hours that we do tomorrow noon
eastern 11 central right here on youtube
twitter and twitch so don't forget to
subscribe to the youtube channel
click the like button leave some
comments
do all the stuff that you're supposed to
do
for the whatever i'm supposed to say for
the youtube channel and you know
do that whatever it is those good things
and if you're out there listening to on
the directories uh make sure to leave us
a five star review with a good review
don't don't be don't be leaving us bad
reviews damn it
uh
only only leave good reviews five star
reviews leave us a review on your
favorite directory even even the
boycotted ones we're on apple google
spotify we're all over the place on the
internet
our voices are gonna be loud and proud
and hard to ignore because we have some
big news coming next week
we can't wait to share this news with
you guys of what of um some things that
are going to be changing
all good things all positive good things
to amplify our voices
and to make sure that the pro-democracy
messages spread around and around and
around and around
so
why don't we uh
do this let's let's get started
you guys want to start the shitless
roundup you want to round up all the
tweety tweets and the trendy trends i
know i do
so
um by the way doesn't it seem like
vladimir putin
has missed his dirt nap appointment
let's start the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome to the shitless
roundup where we round up all the tweety
tweets and the trendy trends of today
uh you know that we go through all of
those trends now we're gonna start off
with the timeline though as as as usual
um they tick down the timeline um this
this here is from sky news let's make
this a little bigger let's make it a
little bigger get my ugly mug off the
screen there for all the views watching
all of you listening get to hear my
beautiful voice but you don't have to
look at my ugly mug but i have to try to
describe
these little things on the screen to you
um so the ukraine ambassador to the u.n
reads out
uh text messages that were sent by a
russian soldier to his mother shortly
before
he died criticizing russian's invasion
to the ukraine um this is uh
kind of a stark video it's pretty long
but let's let's listen to a bit of it
because i would like to read from the
screen
shot of the
smartphone of a smartphone
a killed russian soldier
so he's going to be reading text
messages to a uh from a russian soldier
to his mother
he responded
are you really
enduring in training exercises
especially it might would be to assault
that asks the mother of the killed
soldier
before
he was killed mama yeah
mom i'm no longer in crimea
you know
i'm not in training sessions
again where are you then
whether i can send you
a parcel
i'm in ukraine
so they're the the soldier the russian
soldier who is their mother and father
thinks they're in training
in crimea
obviously
tests to tell the truth to the mother
and the father that thee is no longer in
crimea and they cannot you cannot send a
parcel
don't you know don't you know mama don't
you know i'm in ukraine no they don't
they don't
this is the ruse that russia is trying
to pull over their citizens eyes
and i believe that
the the protest in the streets of russia
is making it clear
it's making it clear that's why
they're protesting
no to war
they are falling under our armored
vehicles
throwing themselves under the wheels and
not allowing us
they call us fascists
that's because
the russian army
is being led
by a fascist tyrant
into a sovereign nation of ukraine
and he won't stop there
he will not he will not stop at that
border
that's the whole key here
this is what they do he doesn't just
want ukraine
he wants all democracy to fall it's what
he wants
that's vladimir putin's delusion
that the only way to remain in power in
russia and anywhere and the world
is for democracy not to exist because
democracy ultimately is his enemy that's
his arch enemy
and he'll look for any friend he can
which is
going to be his demise here
mama this is so hard several moments he
was killed
this was several moments before he was
killed
russian actions
so um there you see um some truth coming
from
from a russian soldier to his family
before moments before he's killed
uh led to slaughter really uh led by
lies and slaughter
here is a picture
this is coming from the kiev uh
independent a pretty reliable source
in ukraine so far
um for reliable um
on the ground news uh russian strikes a
tv tower and kiv um ukrainian tv channel
stopped broadcasting several minutes ago
um so russia is now trying to take down
broadcasting communications
uh in in ukraine uh they're trying to
they're trying to uh make sure you can
see the picture here of the the tower
that was hit
um it seems as if this is probably a
targeted attack there was also a target
attack in freedom square
against the government building we have
video of that and i'm gonna show it we
cannot look away from this stuff you
cannot look away we have to see this the
world needs to see what vladimir putin
wants and the reason why the world needs
to see what vladimir putin wants to do
and is doing to ukraine the reason why
is because we have fascists all over the
world that want to do the same thing
you got it
we have fascists all over the world
there's one down in mar-a-lago who would
love to do the same thing you don't
think he would you don't think he'd sell
out a a
a state or part of this country
for two dollars worth of sanctions you
don't think he'd sell out
i mean hell it was a great real estate
deal
he would love to make a great real
estate deal with canada just ask candace
owens
just ask [ __ ] lauren bobert or
marjorie taylor green they'd love to go
make a real estate deal up there and
invade and take over canada
doubt it doubt what these fascists want
doubt the ends that they'll go to and
the means that they'll use to those ends
just doubt it
what you're seeing right now what
vladimir putin is doing to ukraine
the republicans want to do to states in
this country
what vladimir putin is doing to ukraine
is what republicans the gqp politicians
that are elected in our country want to
do to states in our country
doubt it dare you
they don't want democracy
democracy is their enemy
that is why vladimir putin is doing what
he's doing
that is why he keeps marching into
ukraine no matter what the talks
no matter what the consequences
because he knows that democracy is the
ultimate consequence to his end and his
the end of his regime
so [ __ ] vladimir putin
[ __ ] him
uh
let's move on here down i want to show
uh here of course here's the andrew
clyde thomas massey and chip roy are
putin type [ __ ]
these are the three [ __ ] that
voted
for lynching lynching okay we want
lynching that's what we want to do
pieces of [ __ ]
um
bombing a government building in freedom
square doesn't seem like keeping the
peace to me [ __ ] you vladimir putin
um here is the uh
the video
this is the video of let's go to the
tweet here eric's got it here even the
translators get emotional this morning
two cruise missiles hit freedom square
we're fighting for our land and for our
freedom says president zielinski of
ukraine we have a desire to see our
children alive yet 16 children were
killed now we're gonna watch the video
of the of the bombing but let's listen
to president zielinski of ukraine the
largest square in europe and that's true
this is called the freedom square can
you imagine this morning two peru's
missiles
hit this freedom square
dozens of killed
ones this is the price of freedom
we are fighting
just for our land
and for our freedom
despite the fact
that all large cities of our country are
now blocked
nobody
is going to enter and intervene with our
freedom and country believe you me every
square
of today no matter what it's called it's
going to be called
as today freedom square in every city of
our country
nobody's going to break us
we're strong
we're ukrainians
we have a desire to see our children
alive
i think it's a fair one
yesterday 16 children were killed
again and again president putin is going
to say that is some kind of operation
and we are hitting a military
infrastructure where our children what
kind of military factories do they work
or at
what tanks are they going with or
launching cruise missiles he
so this is a plea um to for president
zielinski and ukraine to be entered into
the block
the european union as he signed a
emergency application to the european
union yesterday now we saw the images of
that
and this is his plea
to continue that effort to become part
of the european union for that
protection
and it's the european parliament that he
was speaking to there
so
um
and here is some of the video
um from the attack
uh this is from the kiev independent
um the russian forces have struck
independence square and century kharkiv
uh i think that's how you say it kharkiv
um with a powerful explosion according
to the video the event the blast
detonated right in front of the
headquarters
of the obas government um it is a
government building
um
and you will see the explosion here do
not
look away
you must see what these fascists want to
do to the world
this is what they want
do not look away
they're bombing government buildings
they're making it clear
that democracy is their enemy
that is not their friend that they will
take over
democratically elected sovereign nations
for nothing other than a push for a
higher and more fascist regime
and a bigger regime even leading their
soldiers
to a death that is a lie here's some
aftermath video of the of that same
square which they are called
freedom
[Music]
you can see the damage here done by the
cars the building the street
russians are attacking the ukraine
capital re republicans tacked our
attacked our capital
makes sense make it make sense
okay um here is um some cleanup this is
from
um another rocket strike
um this is in the freedom square here is
the cleanup effort
where approximately 10 people were
killed
do not look away
do not look away
okay um this is also uh sean walker has
posted this this is a
scene from kiev central station this is
the train station um he says old people
kids disabled people pets this train is
already packed full people fear could be
the last chance to flee as russian
shoulder soldiers more advance their
biggest advancement yet
into ukraine um this is the scene this
is what would happen
in your town
at your train station at your highways
if you let the fascist take
[Music]
over
[Music]
oh this is the great real estate deal
that donald trump the cheeto dust
mobster grandpa poopy pants himself
decided was a great real estate deal
this is the result of that real estate
deal
you know it's such a great deal why
wouldn't putin take that [ __ ] deal
how could putin pass up on a deal to get
an entire country for two dollars worth
of sanctions
because sanctions don't work they're
weak
why wouldn't i would take that deal
donald trump was saying
this is this is the human result
of his great
putin real estate deal that he thinks is
such
such a great transaction
well
i'll let you judge for yourself
now for you out there listening you
might want to come over to the youtube
channel
and watch
and watch these videos then you have
[ __ ] like this this [ __ ] this
[ __ ] this old crotchety [ __ ]
pat robertson
this
i i you know
i can't even believe that this guy is
this
is this the 700 year old club jesus
christ
look at this guy
death four times over really
comes out of retirement to
give more more credence to fascism as if
jesus
as if jesus you know this is god's
calling
this [ __ ]
this vile piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm not
a christian i'm an atheist
i was raised christian i was raised
catholic
that's probably one reason why i'm an
atheist but
here's the thing
what this [ __ ] idiot says right here
has nothing to do with this the sacred
book that christians claim to love
to say to say that god
is chosen putin you piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ] listen listen to what this piece of
garbage says this piece of [ __ ]
garbage i think you can say well putin's
out of his mind yes maybe so but at the
same time he's being compelled by god he
oh he's crazy he's out of his mind he's
being compelled by a gun it's the same
stupid [ __ ] [ __ ] that they said about
trump
yeah he's bad oh he's bad he's there's
nothing good about him but god is
compelling him he's chosen by god get
the [ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ]
i don't know that i could hold a loogie
back if i was in the same [ __ ] room
as this pile of [ __ ] i don't know if i
could do it i really it would take a lot
of [ __ ] willpower to hold back the
biggest loogie that i could hawk i'm
dead [ __ ] serious this this vile
piece of [ __ ] again i'm not a christian
but he
did this type of talk
this type of talk
christians should be [ __ ] ashamed of
themselves
to watch this [ __ ] to claim to to
believe what this [ __ ] idiot believes
to say that vladimir putin's out of his
mind he's murdering people but he's
being called by god
to murder women and children you piece
of [ __ ] [ __ ]
he went into the ukraine yeah he did
wasn't his goal his goal
was to move against israel ultimately
and god is getting ready to do something
amazing
and that will be you [ __ ] stupid
[ __ ]
and people are standing around wondering
why
why people have walked away from [ __ ]
the american christian church
it has it's a disease it's a it's
[ __ ] diseased
it's gross
are you listening out there people who
are still participating in this [ __ ]
garbage
i mean we've seen the writing all over
the wall with trump we knew we knew what
would happen when pat robertson
stroked his ego and made him feel like
he was chosen by god
trump get the [ __ ] out of here now
vladimir putin's murderous ways
that's god's plan
what and you wonder why so many people
are walking away from american
christianity
wonder why get the [ __ ] out of here be
fulfilled and what putin is doing yeah
moving as he is to set up ukraine as as
a
staging ground
for one of the armies and then lacrosse
is his uh you know i said earlier that
putin had missed his appointment for a
dirt nap
this guy hasn't been this guy has missed
it looks like
700 appointments for a dirt nav how old
is this [ __ ] how old is he
i don't know like in his thousands jesus
christ turkey and and you've got between
them that little dardanelle's area and
it's going to happen so i just say
that is what's coming up is putin crazy
is he mad well perhaps
but
yeah yeah he's crazy he's mad he's a
murderous dictator but oh but it's okay
it's okay and we we support him because
why is that you [ __ ] god says i'm going
to put hooks in your jaws and i'm going
to draw you
into this battle whether you like it or
not
and he's being compelled yeah after the
move into the ukraine he's being
compelled to move again to get a land
bridge and then across the dardanelles
with turkey and watch what's going to
happen next you read your bible because
it's coming to pass you're talking about
[ __ ] end time [ __ ] how many times how
many times are they going to talk about
end times how many [ __ ] times how
many times we gonna do this [ __ ] huh how
many [ __ ] times are we gonna have to
do this end time [ __ ]
but there is gonna be end times for
putin
soon
very [ __ ] soon there's gonna be in
times for putin uh here you see um some
nice art made by gabe uh donald trump's
is putin's puppet you might want to
spread this around this is uh this is
pretty good
[Laughter]
you might wanna you might wanna uh find
that on on gage profile and spread that
around a bit here's another one uh
here's another putin's puppet look at
this who is that who is that guy
[Laughter]
ah you [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] we're gonna see more uh
putin's puppets tonight after the state
of the union uh because you know that uh
the the president united states is gonna
stand with ukraine as he should
now he's gonna stand with ukraine and
he's going he's going to
make sure that he has made himself clear
that he is not going to tolerate
uh the murderous dictator putin in his
dictorial ways now we also when we get
into the trendy trends we're going to
see fiona hill
i gave an interview and said yes putin
would use nuclear weapons so a lot of
people are
a lot of concern about that which we
should have we should have concerned
about that so uh caitlin post ukraine's
ukraine strong this meme uh
heaviest objects in the universe the sun
is pretty heavy neutron star the black
hole uranium people's balls you know we
showed this video yesterday and for all
of you who remember the the
uh the cigarette bearing ukrainian who
uh man who carried the land mine across
the road and down into the ditch um
it takes a very heavy set of balls to do
that so
a great meme there oh look here look
here we got another great video that's
dude and remember tucker carlson every
fox news host fully supports putin
what is this let's see what we got here
let's see what's happening inside fox
news who are you and why are you stupid
around in the dark uh we are uh that
accent sounds familiar
wait i know who you are
you must be the interior decorators yes
that is correct as you said we are
interior decorators that is right but i
thought we canceled you guys tucker
decided to decorate the office himself
yes this appears to be true
mission accomplished i guess
infiltrating right-wing news was easier
than we thought wait what was that he
said no no i'm pretty sure he just said
that you were infiltrating our news uh
fake news yes you did look bro sorry to
tell you but putin is taking over
don't you mean fox news
news you're saying
news it's fox news are all americans
this annoying i'll say it slowly f it's
all news
is he trying to snuff out christianity
does he eat dogs
these are fair questions and the answer
to all of them is no vladimir putin
didn't do any of that
putin's puppet tucker
carlson
tucker carlson putin's puppet all right
let's go to the tweety tweets and the
trendy trends here
of course training number three is the
state of the union i'm gonna wait till
gabe comes on and we'll come back to the
state of the union
i want to get his feelings on that um
we also have
do
i want to show you the the scene
um from the u.n
of sergey lavrov as he begins to speak
did it did it get out of the trends here
did it get out of the trends
reload
let's reload
uh
sergey lavrov gives oh tucker carlson is
a russian asset is trending hashtag
number 14 tucker carlson russian asset
no that's perfect
um that dude joe manchin is trending
still
uh
i'm looking for the sergey lavrov
video
and i thought it would trend for a
little bit it was pretty significant
maybe i'm maybe i'm off my rocker maybe
i'm off my rocker
dude
here it is
here it is
okay okay
here's the lavrov um thread
uh you tang
wu tang excuse me wu-tang for children
had this video posted
um
says diplomats getting up and leaving as
russians foreign minister uh lavrov
begins speech at u.n human rights
council in geneva apparently this is a
yearly council that was already
pre-scheduled and it's a human's rights
council as
sergey lavrov and vladimir putin are
backing the russian invasion and killing
and
murdering people and committing war
crimes against people's human rights hmm
let's listen
you can see the
almost the entire room gets up before uh
lavrov starts
uh he's he's in remote because he's
probably in a bunker somewhere in russia
they they dare not leave their bunker
and uh the entire room cleans out almost
there's a few people left
there's a few there's a few pieces of
[ __ ] left in the room
not many
not many
um there is another video here let's
give credit
we give credit
thanks for the tweet thanks for the
video
um
this is the um
that seems like a different room that
seems like a different address
so maybe they did it more than once
um that with the walkout
it appears that way
um here's the other here's the human
rights council
let's see let's go back to the top here
yeah it seems like it's it's done
differently um
that the one walkout was um um for one
maybe this this this looks like a
different one um here's gabe
gabe how are you this morning
i'm good hi everyone everyone welcome
gabe i well i am i'm watching the uh oh
the walk out yeah i'm watching the walk
out here it seems like there's been a
couple walkouts um and maybe it's
because there's different rooms that uh
that he's being broadcast in uh the
first room looked a little different
than than this one here
yeah
i saw the one that uh that hang uh yeah
it was a little different see this one
has all the
the computers or whatever this is this
looks like a
you know this one's a little different
it seems and maybe maybe it's because of
the perspective that i mean i'm sitting
here um so there's this one here but
almost the entire room walks out here
here is uh let's go back let's give
credit here to this one since we showed
it um it's a stark difference between
the president of ukraine this morning
speaking when he got a standing ovation
uh from from a crowd of people it's uh
as he addressed the freedom square being
bombed
right
i don't see the wu tangs uh right that
was it up up up up up
oh that's us well
there it is that's that's the one that i
saw this is the same room
right is it the same room it's just a
different perspective yeah yeah
just seeing it from a different angle
you see how that can get confusing
that's why you got to try to verify
these things
um
we i showed earlier the uh the bombing
of freedom square
um and there's a
video of not just
the bomb itself but also the cleanup and
stuff i i believe that's why everyone is
uh very upset this morning um here's oh
yeah
here's reuters reuters must have had a
different angle is this the same this
looks like maybe it's the same room
different angle yeah this is from the
front looking back so the other ones are
from the back looking front so here is
here's the same we'll cut the sound
here's the same as he comes on screen
this is one i seen earlier um you know
can you imagine trying to be the piece
of [ __ ] that sits there yeah and uh
because this is this is not a
uh an impromptu meeting this has been a
scheduled meeting i guess is that
correct is that what is that how you
read it
oh yeah i mean this is a yearly
yeah yeah you've got to schedule the
scheduled time and everything yeah you
got to be well what i mean
what i mean is this isn't a this isn't
an event because of ukraine
oh you're asking if this is impromptu or
not right right this is this is this is
like this is a meeting that has been
planned for a long time and he's
addressed you know in this room at this
meeting
um
i
don't know look at that look at
everyone's like out of here [ __ ]
i mean they're trying to get somebody
somebody sent out a memo today that was
like okay when it goes on we just leave
um
yeah i don't know if uh
if this was an emergency meeting
you know i i don't i i i can't say for
certain uh okay so so i am i am getting
um i'm mj prompted me earlier to look at
my dms uh thank you mj for sending this
this is um we'll bring this up because
this is relevant um to what we're
talking about here um
this is this morning the
president of ukraine
zielinski spoke to the uh european
parliament
um to get emergency uh acceptance and to
get their application approved to the ue
um breaking this is the key of
independent um
european parliament recommends giving
ukraine eu
candidate status
the decision follows president zlensky's
speech
where he called on the eu to prove that
the union is with ukraine and resolve
also demands that russia withdraw all
its troops from ukraine so it looks like
they're going to get the candidate
backing uh it looks like they got they
were granted the application uh you know
i don't know um what candidate status is
right um but i would assume that
that means at least the application is
moving forward um for ukraine to enter
into the european union which is really
horrible for vladimir putin um it's a
it's a win for democracy
even though you know we've talked about
this several times like
you know ukraine's democracy is not like
fantastic right it's it's very corrupt
um it's not perfect
but they are they but it is a new
democracy right right and and that is
the key here and that is sort of its
vulnerability but
it is proving to be a very good strength
for them that they're not willing just
to hand over their country yeah which
you would you know because vladimir
putin was promising these russian
soldiers that they would just walk in
and they would just be peaceful and
peacefully handed over
right and there would be no death and
they would bow down to the russian army
which they have not and they won't right
and it doesn't appear that they're going
to that they're going to seek nato
they're going to say seek the uh the eu
um to uh
to advance their democrat their cause
for democracy here uh also the with the
president uh zielinski uh with democracy
in mind you know he ran on a uh an
anti-corruption platform
when he became president i don't know if
people remember back that far but he won
just before
um he uh donald trump a president at the
time the cheeto dust mobster started
pressuring him and withholding weapons
and money for weapons which is no
conclusion with russia there's nothing
to see in ukraine
exactly exactly
you know the quid pro quo because he
knew he was going to get his ass spanked
by joe biden which he did
um you know he's right every once in a
while and he was correct when he was
gonna get his ass stopped by joe biden
broken clock is right twice a day it
happens it happens every once in a while
doesn't it um
so i want to go back to the um
uh the state of the union speaking of
the president united states and joe
biden kicking donald trump's ass so what
what do you what do you expect
uh the president to say tonight about i
mean obviously he's gonna have some
words to say about not only ukraine but
putin himself and his feelings about i
mean i think in all like you know
overall he's going to discuss obviously
jobs right the market how we've
recovered uh he's going to probably talk
about
uh coven obviously that's a big one
um and where we are with that
and then obviously the big one is like
where we stand as a world leader
uh and i and i wouldn't be surprised if
that takes up um or if there are there
is some rhetoric you know um if he's
pointing fingers at
the republicans to say
some people in this room
are [ __ ] riling the wrong people up
and because of that
we're seeing a moral decay of our
country
and not only that but we're seeing you
know we're seeing [ __ ] you showed me
a video last night of a of an american
who's fighting on the side of russia
which doesn't make any like with with
for putin which makes no sense yeah yeah
this guy's this guy's from texas or some
[ __ ] or i don't know i mean i you know
it
it sounds about white but at the end of
the day like it also just doesn't
doesn't make any sense right especially
when you're literally watching on tv and
you're watching footage of someone say
uh
what vladimir putin is doing is not
wrong these aren't war crimes he's not
attacking uh innocent civilians you know
um
i look at that and i'm like
i would probably imagine he's gonna have
comments on that it's going to be
probably targeting pointing a finger at
a certain group of people you know
they're
the name starts with re and ends with
publicans
and so
well i mean i mean there were three
republicans that are apparently
pro-lynching i mean i know i
you know thomas thomas massey he's ended
up on bone end of the week like i know
you're telling me that the guy who took
a christmas photo with his family
members holding guns is the same guy
right that is for lynching right because
that's what it is true it's true it says
richie is a hate crime you would assume
that you would say yeah it's pretty
[ __ ] up no one should be lynched
anymore ever no right no and then he and
two other people two other white guys
are the literally the only three
i don't know much about this andrew
clyde i don't know much but i know about
the chip roy that [ __ ] is just
oh you mean andrew clyde this was all
just a tourist visit let me oh is that
chip roy is the guy who he always talks
about lynching he's always talking about
stringing people up and lynching and
yeah you know he loves lynching like he
loves you like i'm not surprised that
chip roy [ __ ] voted for lynching yeah
don't i mean no one should be surprised
that these three white dudes are the
ones that are pro-violence or trying to
justify some sort of uh you know
legitimate political discourse
you know
i mean i mean i i said this morning that
it's it's they're putin type [ __ ] oh
yeah yeah yeah
i mean putin would love to be pro-lin i
mean
putin's pro-lynching probably right
but i look at that and i i see like oh
these three names yep not surprised
whatsoever that they were the ones that
said
no to the bill absolutely it it's right
on brand actually i'm surprised i'm
surprised there was only three of those
[ __ ] right i mean
you would hope that
it's like you would be like listen hey
times are changing all right we can't do
this anymore we shouldn't do this
anymore right uh this should have been a
hate crime a long time ago and
well
what is good back then what if putin
wouldn't have invaded ukraine do you
think they would have been like lauren
beaubert matt gets some of these others
that have kind of backtracked on putin
you think maybe they would maybe they
would have been like yeah lynching
you know i'm not gonna say i'm not gonna
give a hard no on that right yeah yeah
i'll just give a soft pass right uh i
i'd probably say you know matt gates he
would probably say no lauren bobert
she's a real toss-up right margaret
taylor green she's a toss-up as well you
know she's from what i mean i'm not
saying that you know well but she
attended the the uh the nazi rally uh
that is true
i don't know nick fuentes never heard of
seeing a video from fuentes uh but i
happily spoke there i was in email
correspondence i took photos after with
i she don't know nick went to get the
[ __ ] out you know what's funny about
that is there's another interview with
her and two other nazis matt gatz and uh
sebastian gorka um that guy locked me on
twitter i've never done sebastian gorka
i've never once tweeted him or mentioned
your anti it's your anti-putin videos
probably yeah probably
anyway i just got the instant block i
guess by association or he saw something
he's like no he's gonna be mean to me
or his goddamn goatee he didn't he
didn't he didn't want the gate he didn't
ever want the possibility of him ending
up in a gay video probably but here's
the thing
he might now yeah but he was he wasn't
in my he wasn't in my sights before but
right now how did you how did you know
he blocked you
uh somebody tweeted something and it
said i couldn't see it oh okay what the
hell is this like oh it's from whatever
and then i had to go to like incognito
window to look at and i was like who the
[ __ ] oh my god this guy blocked me
the guy who yeah whatever i was like big
how powerful alpha male 1
oh yeah
there's an alpha cuck for the week but
no so so basic orca and uh marjorie
taylor green and matt getz they were
having a nazi get-together um for
sebastian yeah yes for sebastian's
trader tv um you know
his channel not not steve bannon's
channel right right but but anyways they
they were doing their little trees in
this thing and uh um they were marjorie
taylor green was saying oh well no one
mentioned me or donald trump having
their accounts canceled which nick
fuentes
has very been popularly known that he
got kicked off twitter so she knows who
this [ __ ] is yeah like she's in the
group of people like she's like there's
a list of fascists that got kicked off
twitter
she's on that list with him
you know they're they're the uh shitty
humans of the month they all have those
awards on the wall you know when you
walk down it's like who has been banned
from this place for saying stupid
dumbass [ __ ] right they're both they're
right they're side by side you know uh
you know speaking of saying dumb ass
[ __ ] uh bp points something out here and
i always like to call myself that
because i make mistakes
oh yeah eu yeah well see uh there is a
ue here well it's not it's not called ue
anymore
in missouri there there was a company
called union electric and it was ue so i
i i
got it confused i'm sorry i will try to
keep to the eu thing the european
european
union union yeah the union yes but um um
the european parliament is where uh the
president zlolinsky and apparently they
have done that um back to the state of
the union
we have uh um
fred o'wellman here says hey democratic
campaigns do yourself a favor and have
your team ready for when president biden
talks about supporting ukrainian
criticizes putin during the state of the
union make sure you capture your gop
which i would say gqp opponent not
not stand up to clap yeah i have a
feeling we'll see who is missing
paychecks oh yeah people are yeah people
are gonna i've i'm sure people are gonna
screenshot the the the thing too with
this is
um
i feel like it was like years ago i read
this and i mean it could be different
now just because of how like polarized
both sides are but it was i think it was
a
uh
2010 maybe there was a union i was
reading an article and they were like
assessing like oh here are the trends
that happen like you can you can kind of
see what the
the temperature check is at the
beginning based on
how many people stand up and uh applaud
the president once he walks in and like
greets
right greets the chambers
uh and that'll give you a sense of
overall like is it are you know it could
just be one party clapping and cheering
on or is it going to be
uh a mixed bag of both sides of the
aisle that are clapping and applauding
when
um when the president says something so
they say that's like a like a gut check
for like how the the whole thing's gonna
go obviously right now we've got the gdp
who's just like anything that's
anti-biden they are for
so
you know it's hard to say but
uh
i wouldn't be surprised if there were
people that you know
sitting down on their phone falling
asleep or whatever during this parts and
obviously their silence
is you know is deafening well here's
here's an example of this here's what
they're going to do
thomas massey is putting the writing on
the wall here that [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
uh look at this tweet because marco
rubio said he's not gonna take a covet
test um thomas massey says i'm healthy
no you you're a healthy piece of [ __ ]
that's for
sure um
you know steaming pile of healthy [ __ ]
so i won't be taking a test for covid so
i won't be attending the state of the
union here's what they're going to do
they're going to use this test thing not
not to support it to show their support
for poo because they don't want to they
they have to show support for putin but
they can't do it in front of the cameras
at the state of the union so i think
this is they're out um by the way thomas
massey you treason this piece of [ __ ]
you're trying to [ __ ] suck yeah go
[ __ ] yourself
uh yeah i could i mean i i look at that
and i say uh are you sure you want to
tweet this uh i i look at this and i'm
just like yeah this this cop out right
like that don't you think don't you
think that's what they're doing here
yeah no it's a complete cop-out it's the
same tactic that somebody takes when
like a little kid
doesn't like the way that things are
going they it's the i'm going to take my
ball and i'm going home
and obviously they don't have control
the state of the union because it's not
their show they're just there as
attendees to hear the president say kind
of what the state of the union is right
what's going on in our country and also
abroad
and i look at these people who are like
you know big pouty faces
and uh they just
they just uh they don't wanna
they're just such little i better watch
them they are they i know they are they
are babies uh they are having a tantrum
because they're not getting what they
want
and the guy that they want in office is
not there nor will he be again because
i'm sure he's not running in 2024 it's
all a [ __ ] grift he's gonna take
people's money he's gonna have more
rallies he's not actually gonna end up
running because of some [ __ ] reason
you know
um
but yeah people like thomas massey are
uh are stains on this country's
uh
yeah just a stain stain on anything
really right yeah and so i i i look at
this i admire
stains in my underwear more than i
admire just the skid marks of america's
underwear that's what they are shittiest
but yeah i see that and i say like all
these people are going to use this as an
excuse oh i don't want to wear a mask
i'm not taking a cover test it's like
oh my god didn't you guys this this
account right here when there's
something the other day that you had oh
god this one this guy who is this this
idiot
this guy made a post the other day he's
like can we just invoke the 25th
amendment and bring trump back into
office and it's like one that's not how
it works uh there
there's a list of people below the
president who replaced the president
if he gets the 25th amendment invoked if
he goes then it's the vice president
they go it's the uh
house you know and like they're there
and there's a whole cha there's a look
at this look at this look at this tweet
though look at this tweet from this
[ __ ] idiot
um
i i'm not saying to go [ __ ]
uh you know hammer on this guy but don't
forget to add the nothing at a dollar
store as a dollar to joe biden's list of
accomplishments tomorrow you mean what
changes that were made
this is hilarious also people don't
understand what taxes are so if it's 99
cents you're gonna get taxed so it's
gonna go okay right yeah it's gonna go
over now but but but uh in the midwest
there's a store called dollar general
like it's called dollar general right
yeah now i'm sure at one point dollar
general's business model that everything
was a [ __ ] dollar right everything
was a dollar it's not that way it hadn't
been that way for [ __ ] years you go
buy a shirt it's not at ours like
dollars
right right it just
this
what what's funny about this is they're
trying to be populist right they're like
oh
oh gas prices up and i have to i have to
spend 200 to fill up my obnoxiously big
truck that i don't need
right to drive to drive two hours to
work and hang some metal nuts on the
back of my right right will i have to
look cool gabe i have to look cool in my
truck
people have to think i have a big dick
and if they don't think i have a big
dick
then then what would i do how could i
survive my masculinity how would
everyone know that i i'm i'm a machismo
type macho man these [ __ ] idiots you
know what they do you know what they do
to prove it when they don't have a truck
or hanging metal nuts off the back of
the truck
is they go on and they try to bully
people
and make fun of them for
little things it's like i'm not gonna
i'm not going to attack your point uh
because of a political standpoint or a
policy or an ideology i'm gonna attack
you
on being you like you as a person i'm
gonna attack your weight your looks
uh your intelligence all the stuff and
you know it's those like well let's just
have a debate in good faith it's like
it's never in good faith
so whenever i see these arguments it's
like don't forget to add nothing to a
dollar store it's a dollar joe biden's
list of accomplishments tomorrow no uh
you are using this as an attack that is
not actually a real attack against joe
biden uh for these things were changing
before joe biden was in office
i wonder i wonder if um if people are
concerned about their dollar store items
going from you know like a dollar to a
dollar ten dollar 25 whatever whatever
if they're if they would be worried
about if they had decent [ __ ] wages i
wonder if they would be worried about
that if in this country
people could walk around knowing that
they had a retirement for when they
retire i wonder i wonder if people would
worry about dollar store items in this
country if they just made sure that they
wouldn't go bankrupt over a medical bill
i wonder i wonder if
if people in this country would be so
concerned about dollar store items
being
exactly a [ __ ] dollar if
if we can make sure to which we can't
afford that everyone gets a decent
education from the age three to age 22 i
wonder
if we could if the if these people if
you really think about it deeply if you
really think about these issues
rather dollar store items would be their
main concern bearded vet
the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ] okay
um
so let's see what else we got of course
you know you got all these they're
they're you know they're going to try to
clown here's another [ __ ] thomas
massey tweet and this course is from a
couple days ago so no telling what the
hell that's going on with that uh let's
see if we get some more bucks sexton of
course that's probably a hot take uh
marsha blackburn we're not even gonna
[ __ ] listen to that turd
um they all got hot takes i'm here i'm
sure here yeah um of course who who is
their uh who's their roundup for their
response do you know who the
no i don't know i mean is it gonna be
sipping watermark rubio i don't know i
don't know remember remember when uh
remember when uh
rand paul i think it was rainbow they
all they all do their own responses now
like i'm sure ted cruz will do his
response because he won't ask dude so
he'll do his everyone will do their own
little their own little response but i
don't know who the official response is
from um if you got a
uh
yeah i know
let's see who i'm trying to
look this up right now
but i would imagine that joe biden is
going to run laps uh about the success
that he's had um we're trying to
uh get current iowa governor kim
reynolds delivers this oh kim reynolds
oh a fantastic oh that's what those
that's what those graphics were wasn't
that kim reynolds that you were just
scrolling by the second yeah there you
go right there yep there it is oh
that's [ __ ] hilarious
oh the end of her career that iowa has
to be pleased about this iowa has to be
like this is fantastic because have you
ever have you ever noticed that when a
republican responds
to the state of the union that they're
they remember remember bobby jindal
remember that remember that oh yeah he's
a governor and he came from louisiana
yeah it took him like 12 minutes to get
to the spot on the floor like the x
because you know they had an x on the
sport right right right yeah it took him
like 12 minutes to get there and it took
him a while like he just stood there
like someone's not like okay go
like go go go go
go and then and then he gave and it was
horrible
and he just i remember at one point
somebody i i think the the republicans
are like this is this is the republicans
barack obama and i was like who who
bobby jindal oh yeah that's right that's
right that's right i wonder i wonder
what state of the union that was that
was probably like 2010. well that was
probably the you lie the you lies day
the union oh yeah
probably that one oh yeah okay and you
remember when they when uh what's his
dick
you lie
you lie which is you look back on
hindsight and you're like wow
wow for the republicans to be the ones
the one that came from there it's like
oh sorry he didn't lie but okay right
so tucker carlson russian asset is
trending
now i've seen that this was trending
earlier but um and i tweeted out of
somebody's video uh with the hashtag and
i thought oh this one's gonna peter out
but it has not it is taking hold huh
it's fox news uh they're they're
they're robbing um this is uh
this was uh
posted by midas a couple days ago but
this is eric swalwell on
on
cnn but it's cnn on fox news you follow
me it's
double dipping here so let's listen to
this we have republicans who are rooting
for russia and that makes it very hard
for president biden to get the whole
country to go along when donald trump
mike pompeo and tucker carlson are
rooting for russians and that's being
replayed on russia tv to rally russians
for this cause you know it's such an
awful thing to say we hesitated even
in common you hear it oh it's such an
awful truth to tell
why
why would you tell that truth for crying
out loud how disgusting how disgusting
to tell the truth the [ __ ] out of here
tucker you piece of [ __ ] let's listen
today
the question is why are they saying that
it doesn't make sense but is there
another reason you should side with
ukraine over russia russia is a much
more significant country by every why is
it disloyal to side with russia
but
in mind
foreign countries that don't care
anything about the united states look
the reason why it's wrong tucker is
because he's a murderous tyrant yeah he
kills i'm just saying this is not
unusual to be asking these questions
because i'm an inquisitive man
i'm an inquiring mind right i'm just
here asking the questions
don't come at me yeah what great
questions he has what great what great
questions tucker forms i wonder who is
the the the piece of [ __ ] that actually
uh writes these out into the prompter
because you know it's not tucker right
and all that oh yeah no there's some
person who has no soul who has oh [ __ ]
who is you imagine that vile piece of
[ __ ] can you imagine trying to like sit
across the table and need to sandwich
with this guy and you know it's a white
dude you know it's a [ __ ] white dude
dude i i can only imagine those meetings
where they're like all right so because
obviously some of the stuff is written
right beforehand
and uh and some of this stuff is
obviously
it's like right before like oh this is
breaking news i'm here as to you know
it's like i'm tucker carlson and tonight
we talk about how joe biden eats dogs
and it's like what are you you know it's
like never did putin eat dogs who wrote
that who the [ __ ] wrote that i don't
know
i don't know i mean i mean
i mean we we we worked on and you made a
skit where you were eating your own poop
right
right like that was and it was parody
and satire but these people are sitting
around tables and they're they're
serious about like yeah you really
whether you know and obviously remember
this is not actual news this is
entertainment right he had lawyers uh
uh well yeah fox news had to defend
themselves a couple times be like no
person in their right mind
would believe what tucker says
if you believe what he says
you're an idiot you know right so look
i'm sorry but if you're that gullible or
you believe these crazy conspiracies
that he pushes even after the fact you
know and then you'll tell someone it's
like well tucker's own lawyers had to
get out of a lawsuit by claiming that it
wasn't news it's just entertainment and
then
you know even then they're like uh this
is this is fake news this is fake news
fake news you know right it's
that's what it is that's all they have
they have i mean like they did the same
thing they did the same thing with the
big lie though
like i had a well i had a dude who is
commenting on my instagram post about uh
uh about it was i was like oh one year
ago here we are ted cruz fled to cancun
right right and this guy was like oh is
this when aoc went to florida and didn't
wear a mask where masks are not required
right uh and i go no this is the time
when aoc raised 5 million
[Laughter]
when ted cruz fled to cancun and then
blamed it on his daughters right and i
was like come back and he come back and
he did the paper towel thing he was just
throwing bottles of water instead of
paper towels and then then this guy
keeps commenting [ __ ] about like
yeah but yes ted cruz comes back and
he's like oh you know just for the photo
get me a photo carrying out of the back
seat of this car you know right but yeah
i've got dumb people that come out all
the time and those are the same dumb
people who try to double down and be
like no no no fake news that wasn't real
it's like dude hear a bunch of links
like ap reuters uh here's even fox news
covering aoc racing here's them saying
it
and these people are like no
why can you post links in here and i
can't and i'm like i i don't know it
sounds like a user error but how are we
on that subject you're trying to deviate
from what i'm just proving you wrong
instagram hates hates fascists that's
why
let's listen let's listen to fascist man
himself here i know which is the actual
threat why would we take ukraine's side
why wouldn't we have russia's side i i
don't i'm totally confused so much he's
totally completely confused he's only
confused
as putin there's a moment
sorry just play the clip but i'll do it
after
has he threatened to get me fired for
disagreeing with him has he shipped
every middle-class job in my town to
russia i should say for the record i'm
totally opposed to the to these
sanctions and and i i don't think that
we should be war with russia and i think
we should probably take the side of
russia
if we have to choose between russian
ukraine that is my view but
i'm serious
and why shouldn't i root for russia
which i am
why should i root for russia which i am
i've seen someone who did a video where
they were uh
where was his laugh he's like
you know like the thing and then they
they they took it and they did it like
oh this around you with a joker
and uh
his high-pitched voice where he's like
somebody tell me why you go down he's
like why so serious you know it's like
it gets into that like that's where he's
leading in his at least in the
high-pitched tone that he is [ __ ]
freaking out
are you saying that that that somewhere
deep down inside tucker carlson is a is
a joker somewhere
you think he's a joke you know some
people just want some people are saying
burn you know some people are saying
many people
many people are saying uh that you know
uh
some people some some men just want to
see the world burn you know that's what
i'm saying
oh this
please don't spread this one around the
internet
you know we we do a we do a
tuckerson we should make carl tuckerson
really pissed off that there's a parody
of him on a on a news station called
called [ __ ] news
and and he's really he's smooth books
news and he's really he's really pissed
off that someone is trying to parry to
him
um and his you know because it's uh
white privileged his show white
privilege tonight we have a yeah we have
a character called the carl tuckerson
with the show called white privilege
tonight maybe maybe that's what we do is
get him all riled up and he starts
showing clips of people making fun of
him over on fox news it's a fake news
channel [ __ ] news i like i like the
video by the way the fox news it's good
um just announced tucker is still a
[ __ ]
i mean you know breaking non-breaking
news
carlson is still a [ __ ] terrible
person
still news still news still news now
right still news now oh my god okay
let's go back to the tweety tweets and
transgenders how much time do you got
today to hang with us you gotta look
like 15. okay good let's um let's go
down to uh
now the tucker was fun
um what else do we have here andrea
mitchell's trending again
who knows why you want to do that one or
you want to do joe mance and joe manson
oh god bring him down the vote of roe v
wade for the um
um the they wouldn't codify it yeah
wouldn't codify for the
you know you know
it um it really does seem and you know
the unfortunate part about
the senate right now and the um the the
makeup of the senate is joe manchin is
not under up for re-election so there's
really not a damn thing we can do about
joe manchin at this point and really
honestly joe manchin is the only
democrat that's going to win in west
virginia and luckily his race doesn't
depend on our majority this time yeah um
you know yeah actually you know a lot of
people are bitching about him but really
honestly him not being
in the race this time for this midterm
is a good thing that means we don't have
to [ __ ] worry about that seat he's a
democrat we'll keep the majority all we
need to do is worry about florida ohio
and some of these other seats that are
out there that are available uh for
democrats to pick up
who set out of this vote um you know i
don't know let's let's let's see if we
can like it would go 47-47 and then and
then harris would have her come in and
tie breaks because the senators duly
chosen and swore not having voted in the
affirmative the motion is not agreed to
on this vote the yeas are 46 the nays
are 48 three-fifths of the senators i
swear to god joe manchin voted he the
game he pleases he waits agreed to till
the very end he becomes the person that
everyone wants to [ __ ]
please well i mean here's the thing is
is uh one of the reasons why is so that
me and you are talking about not me and
you specifically
everyone's talking about him i mean
obviously now joe manchin wants to
pretend to be president i mean he loved
to be president and he seems to be
president in the in the senate because
he gets to make these decisions at the
last moment yeah um now again amy points
out here too that it wasn't the bill
that failed it was just the [ __ ]
threshold to to overcome a filibuster
right so it wasn't it wasn't that they
were voting against it is that they
wouldn't even [ __ ] vote to debate it
yeah right i mean that's the thing here
we don't want we don't even you're like
we don't even want to talk about it
right right it it really it really is um
telling that they don't want it debated
right i mean
to me to me that's more telling than
whether they vote yey or nay i mean it's
the same it's the same [ __ ] with the
books you know it's the same stuff with
history if it's out of sight it's out of
mind if we don't talk about it it means
it's not a problem
if we remove from history it means it
never happened
if we don't if we don't have it you know
recorded or logged or
or codified in something then hey it's
just hearsay you know these are just
rumors these are just things that you
hear about but you don't actually
experience yourselves you know it's like
racism not really a thing according to
republicans well as long as you don't
have to debate it on the floor of the
senate right yeah
i mean why why
if as long as you don't have to debate
it on the floor of the senate then it
doesn't exist gabe uh scary larry says
while we're
[Music]
while you weren't looking joe manchin
voted with republicans against codifying
roe vs wade today of course he did
because he's not really a democrat and
he's a misogynistic [ __ ] i believe i
believe joe manchin 100 is an [ __ ] um
i tweeted the other day these [ __ ]
and everyone knew who i was talking
about like
as soon as i don't got to tell me you
know yeah right
if it looks like a duck and it swims
like a duck and it's a quacks like a
duck it's probably a [ __ ] republican
right amy
right amy lynn uh or a joe manchin uh
pretending to be a democrat uh joe
manchin doesn't think women should have
the ability to make decisions for their
own bodies see and this this is the game
that joe manchin is gonna play because
here's what he's gonna say well it's not
that i it's not that i agree or disagree
with the bill
i just think that the filibuster
filibuster filibuster filibusting
filibusters and the filibusters is
democratic in this part of the country
right which would have nothing to do
with this because they didn't even have
enough votes so if it was 47 47 then you
look at this and say like well it's tied
we don't have the 60 to get the
uh to get the actual debate on
so if he really wanted to do it that way
he could have been like yeah i voted for
it but we didn't have enough so don't
blame me
as opposed to
i didn't even give you my vote to talk
about it which i think is is there's a
lot going on there deeper which is i
don't know if he can really walk away
and be like well it's not like you know
like i was i he could have totally said
like i was open to discuss about it like
i may have different political views or
ideologies about this but i'm happy to
open a dialogue right and he could have
voted and been like all right i see
where this thing's going i'm going to
vote for it be on the record that i'm
open to talking about it but i don't
actually have to talk about it because
we didn't have the majority because the
filibuster works you know it's like yeah
well yeah because it it it prevents them
from having to actually talk about it i
haven't debated it uh and so now adolf
twittler's the slayer says there as you
can see uh for the audience listening
joe manchin hates women never forget i i
doubt that women are going to forget
this about joe manchin oh yeah and about
republicans in general i believe um i
think that's gonna be the case uh so
let's go back to tweet tweets you got
about ten minutes five minutes ten
minutes okay let's see if we can find
another topic here yeah uh we are
18 minutes into the second hour um
let's see you want to do sports you want
to do uh brokeback mountains up there
joe manchin i'm just let's see what
andrea mitchell said yeah let's see what
this is going on
um um
outspoken says so andrew mitchell
decides to have marco rubio discuss
ukraine right what
see this is the you know a lot of people
don't like andrew mitchell mitchell
and the reason why is because and i
don't know if it's her her producers i
really don't um but
her show they really do go to
extended ends to make sure they have the
dumbest [ __ ] at the dumbest
possible times on their shirt to say the
dumbest [ __ ] right like and now that
you're giving you're giving legitimacy
to dumb
people who have dumb things to say and
now you've established and and you've
platformed someone and legitimized what
they had to say unless you're going to
use them as a
uh
as a gotcha moment to say you're wrong
about
uh ukraine and russia and what you've
been saying
and you just and and if you don't do
that and you just let them talk
and then ask some follow fluff questions
then you're not doing anyone any any
good right you're just letting them
spread the gospel that is pro-russia
anti-ukraine pro-putin
anti-zilinski you know you know
the ability to spread anti-democratic
viewpoints is what it is
so i've noticed this when andrew
mitchell and i i mentioned this the last
time she trended and i i was going
through the thread on on the show here
i've noticed that when andrew and
mitchell trends there's there's no
[ __ ] clip
there's no clip yeah like anyone else
right anyone else anyone else who trends
in the news whether it be rachel or
joanne reed or tucker carlson or you
know whoever slimeball
is the media man i guess i don't know
but dare literally like several times
it's all third hand or second hand or
like fourth hand here's the best shot we
got right
it's just can i get a video though
like what's i don't know i don't know
you know there's a lot of people out
there that use softwares where they're
actually like watching and clipping as
it's happening but nobody does it no one
no
they don't for andrea mitchell right
they don't watch they don't record her
show because there's never a clip i mean
she trends because she has stupid people
on saying stupid things right and
normally she's trying to respond and she
doesn't get to the the response that she
should have not quickly not that's why
people don't watch the show probably but
the point is this is that
is that they never have a clip
of it and like chuck todd always a clip
always
fast quick and in a hurry so someone
someone out there is not watching or not
you know clipping
um because again there's software's out
there that people use that that take the
clip in real time and they can just pull
it out really fast and then post it to
like social media yeah for some for an
instance like this where marco rubio
would say stupid [ __ ] on her on her show
but there isn't a clip you'd have to be
watching and i don't i don't watch i
don't watch cable i don't have a table
um but
it's very very very odd that um and i've
noticed this
i mean i've actually wait wait wait i
got it i got it you got it yeah yeah
yeah you know who shared it senator
marco rubio uh of course of course let's
just send it over here let's let's go
let's go see what this stupid [ __ ] marco
rubio says apparently he's not going to
take a coba test earlier he was uh
he was he was turning so uh uh
you know i i guess um oh this is a
youtube link yeah
we're leaving the tweety tweets and the
trendy trends everybody yeah we're going
we're going to the tubes we're going to
the tubes of you we're going to the
tubes of you republican senator marco
rubio of florida who of course is the
vice chairman of the intelligence
committee also senior member of the
foreign relations committee uh senator
thank you it really is rough
when when marco rubio is
and and you know i know intelligence you
know means like information but it just
it's ironic right right yeah okay very
much i just wanted to uh read something
that just came from president zlinski
and has been confirmed by the white
house doesn't he look like he's about to
cry i mean i hate to point this out but
yeah he needs he needs to like surely he
can afford some like botox or something
i mean i don't know me
he really he looks really sad to be on
andrea's show here that he and the
president president biden have been on
the phone they've been talking this
morning
the zielinski
tweet is just had a conversation with
potus the american leadership on
anti-russian sanctions and defense
assistance to ukraine was discussed we
must stop the aggressor as soon as
possible thank you for your support
so
are we doing enough what more do we need
to do what would you what do you want to
see from the u.s well look i think that
what's happened over the last you know
week is really unprecedented i mean the
russian economy is headed towards
collapse the ruble most certainly is and
and that's something i don't think
anybody including putin anticipated i
think he thought he would get hit hard
but not this what the [ __ ] is he talking
about
what has he taught
the president of the united states the
state department
and the nato has been warning for weeks
that they are going to destroy the
russian economy
this is a [ __ ] sitting united states
center on the intelligence committee
and he's going to listen no one could
have anticipated no one could have ever
imagined no one could ever imagine what
the hell the administration
was going to do they were just saying
what the hell they were going to do the
whole time i mean hell i there's
probably video of marco rubio bitching
about how sanctions aren't tough enough
and they aren't going to work and
they're not going to shut down the
russians there's probably clips there's
probably [ __ ] clips
there are a couple things we have to
start thinking through i think the first
is and you've pointed to it in that
reporting before i came on the air the
the unique uh
aspects of this refugee crisis that is
largely women and the elderly and young
children
whose fathers and husbands have are
still in ukraine and may make it back
and may not who knows when they'll be
reunited and so that's a unique aspect
of it these are people that a week ago
were living normal lives going to school
running their businesses going to work
and a week later find themselves in a
tent city and so that's something we
certainly need to keep an eye on and
provide all the assistance we can along
with everybody around the world
to help them in the short term the
second is
look putin can't win i mean he's headed
to one of two directions here he's
either headed towards a very costly
military victory or he's headed towards
a quagmire which is his military can't
achieve victory even the costly military
victory he's going to have to stay there
forever and face an insurgency he's not
just fighting another military he's
fighting 40 something million people
that don't want his forces there and no
matter what he does he'll never be able
to install some puppet traitor
government that he can just get up and
leave and leave them behind because the
ukrainians will overthrow them and kill
those people
so there's marco rubio given his hot
take on ukraine um uh giving giving a
hot take about three weeks too [ __ ]
late yeah i know um really honestly we
don't know what was going to happen and
these people were living their normal
lives like and now now putin can't make
it now putin can't handle it and now
putin can't do the thing you know this
is the same i think i believe that he
was a sitting senator
when there was a president of the united
states i believe that president's name
was donald trump uh he actually he
actually uh did a quid pro quo i don't
know if anyone remembers this but he he
withheld weapons from the same country
that he's talking about ukraine
um in the defense from russia because
the it seemed at the time that that
attack may be imminent and uh obviously
it was now uh but he actually he i think
marco rubio
voted to make sure that the president
who actually didn't give weapons and
funding for those weapons to ukraine i
think he voted
i'm pretty sure he was a senator at the
time i'm sure he voted for that
president to remain the president i'm
just saying and i think that was the
first impeachment trial i wonder what
his vote was on the second one when he
tried to overthrow our government and
the insurgency in our country get the
[ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ]
i'm i'm i can't i can't do it anymore
i'm going to marco
yeah little marco little [ __ ] marco
yeah
so
back to the trendy trends ed you know
uh women's history history month is
number one um which uh march marks the
uh beginning of women's history month
and how does joe manchin do within
women's history month he shits all over
it brings it in real nicely for right
right and you know we shouldn't we
shouldn't we shouldn't uh um
leave out all the republicans who voted
against
against uh
women's body autonomy as well um we
should also recognize those pieces of
[ __ ] garbage uh state of the union is
trending number two now so it's moving
up the ladder uh
let's see if we got anything of course
tucker carlson russian assets moving up
the ladder gabe it's getting to number
11.
number 11 is coming i might have to
might have to re-share that video
well
i got to it first with the hash pixel
so there you go uh let's see if we can
go into the for you of course thomas
massey hypocrite is trending so uh uh
republican is trending republicans
trending uh matt gatz is trending oh
baby let's go into this one
um
let's see if we've got an avenger
resistor says how and godzilla green
earth and matt gatz rick scott and marco
rubio ever get elected
i assume we can do better florida yeah
yeah i i agree i agree um
did he do something what what did matt
get i mean
or should i say what he did he didn't do
yeah what did he not do i don't know
it's like any time those guys walk in a
room everyone's like oh i don't know i
mean like at cpac he was like in charge
of the entertain or not in charge of the
entertainment but he had he went wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait are you
telling me that the guy who vin mode
entertain entertainment
they had that guy in charge of booking
entertainment for i don't know if he was
in charge of booking entertainment but
he certainly went on stage to go hang
out with the guy that's that uh that
made that song uh f joe biden
oh you know hang out with him so wait
what are you yeah he was on stage he was
on stage and he was like dancing he was
like
like very
very white guy kind of dance you know
who's like yeah yeah
it was very it was very weird
there's a video of it it's out there
here's here this must be why he's
trending because he he's [ __ ]
tweeting of course that's probably why
he's training because he's a dumb [ __ ]
um a complete dumb [ __ ] something i just
can't wait for the fbi raid to happen
you know yeah well you know
do you do you already have do you
already have video already made to have
that uh no but i'm sure uh
i'm sure i can make one i mean i mean
here's
i did one i did one for rudy which was
like fbi raiden they found all the stuff
i've got another one i think i'm gonna
wait because obviously you know the more
important stuff happening right now is
like russia ukraine but there's another
video i have that's in the
in the like ready to go
which is
the archives team and all of the stuff
that they found that they like logged
back in the boxes it's like shredded
documents and you know the love letter
from
uh
from kim jong-un and this and this and
there's all these different little items
so what about the what about the state
of union speech that nancy pelosi ripped
up it was it in those boxes too i don't
know i'm just no no no no now that we're
out there there was a union there was a
there was an ebay listing for the
lincoln the abraham lincoln bust
uh you know there was a love letter from
kim jong-un there were blueprints for
the white house plumbing made by joe the
plumber oh okay uh yeah that's that's in
case that's in case you flush something
and you get a yeah yeah it was like you
know if if something goes wrong then do
this you know right right right so matt
getz it is responding in a quote tweet
uh big escalation here by meta against
russia state media links are being
demoted
in the news feed globally and not
recommended anywhere
and here's here's what this [ __ ] says
breaking meta treating russia state
media like they've treated republicans
for years hmm i wonder if you're on to
something there matt gatz
what how the [ __ ] can't this big
four-headed bastard he runs straight
into the [ __ ] point
like you're running
you're running headfirst into the point
why why meta which is facebook
is suppressing [ __ ] disinformation
right treating us they're treating them
like republicans
exactly yeah did you share stuff before
that was proven to be false
did you share stuff that was proven to
be
uh
farmed out of uh like out of russia with
russian bots and disinformation
looks like you just got the answer my
guy
let's see if i can get the
let's see if i can get suspended here
[Music]
[ __ ] him i don't give a [ __ ] your
[ __ ] tweet sucks dude you're [ __ ]
not only does your tweet sucks you
[ __ ] suck
and it sucks to suck i'm better metas
treating russian state media like
they've treated republicans for years
yeah no [ __ ] sherlock yeah like oh my
god mother [ __ ]
that fat [ __ ] forehead runs straight
into the [ __ ] truth and he came
it goes right right
he runs straight into the point like i
mean head first forehead first into it i
guess you'd say
oh my god this [ __ ] what an idiot what a
[ __ ] idiot oh [ __ ]
and of course he's tweeting more [ __ ]
here but i think that's i think that's
the reason why he's starting to uh the
trend is probably that it's got to be
that tweet there's no way it's not that
dumb oh yeah probably i mean either that
or you know people are just like oh mac
let's make sure everyone remembers
and i don't want to whisper that matt
gates is a [ __ ] pedophile he's a sex
trafficker [ __ ] that guy
yeah
and we'll find out more about that um
as as the as the months tick on if he
hasn't already started to make a deal i
i think you have to go thanks gabe for
joining us everyone say bye to gabe um
but hang in there
we're gonna take a break uh we'll be
right back after this message
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
headline
[Music]
under president joe biden the american
economy adds 467
000 new jobs in the month of january
thanks brandon
[Music]
[ __ ] em
[ __ ] em [ __ ]
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the
thanks for show in with the break
having fun with gabe
co-host executive producer of the tony
michaels podcast
every single weekday noon eastern 11
central
we're we're at a minute uh 34 into the
second hour
um
someone brought this up in the chat
earlier i believe and i wanted to get to
it um it appears uh aaron parnez here uh
he's the host of zoomed in uh podcast
that is
part of the midas media network uh
vladimir putin wants to de-nazify
ukraine is the quote yet just bombed a
holocaust memorial uh killing five
innocent civilians putin is a war
criminal
which is this shouldn't be surprised now
aaron tweeted this about an hour ago
i'm not sure exactly when this happened
it looks like it happened about the same
time that they were attacking a ra the
radio tower
so it is um holocaust is trending that's
one reason why i wanted to get to that
uh so i appreciate uh whoever it was in
the chat that had brought that up i
appreciate you you pointing it out i
wanted to get to that um andrew says
here uh putin's now bombing holocaust
memorials and his effort let's make this
a little bigger so you can see um in his
effort to denazify ukraine
the country with democratically elected
jewish president that's the other crazy
part is zelinski president zielinski is
a is jewish i don't understand
um why people think this is de-nazifying
um
we've seen a video of uh
this [ __ ] box from texas um saying this
denotification [ __ ] it's it's all
propaganda
um
to to make russians believe that they're
in the cause the good cause with
vladimir putin um here is um let's go
back i think i can find
let's see if i can find this video
of this um this vile vile creature um
from texas american he's a traitor
really and i don't i don't know what the
law is but i would imagine if this guy
comes back to this country here it is
hirotez and i said what a f
what the [ __ ] is this trees in this [ __ ]
um
i have this video posted
uh just a good old boy apparently
embedding with russian forces in ukraine
so apparently this guy is some kind of
[ __ ] like um i don't know he's he's a
pseudo-famous person there
i don't know for being i guess i don't
know if he's just from being from texas
and he's he's pro putin
i don't know i don't know what the hell
well watch watch this [ __ ] video this
crazy ass treasonous piece of
with the d [ __ ] fires and liberators of
ukraine see listen listen to what he
says denotes a fire listen to that
with the d nazi fires and liberators of
ukraine okay so this is this is
important in their language right these
right-wingers do this all the [ __ ]
time they do it they do it with like the
antifa thing right everything's antifa's
fault they don't understand what the
[ __ ] antifa means they don't understand
what it says they [ __ ] they they
always [ __ ] around with this stupid [ __ ]
right so what happens is like like
antipa they're calling you know people
identify themselves as anti-fascists not
only identify themselves but take the
actions of anti-fascists right and
they're like no you're the fascist so
here here's this it's the same [ __ ]
it's the same [ __ ] like
ukraine is an imperfect democracy most
are even ours is an imperfect democracy
jesus christ we've seen what happened on
january 6th and we've seen how we can
actually elect tyrants ourselves or
wannabe tyrants you know if if they
could clean up their diaper long enough
to [ __ ] put their thoughts together
to be a dictator you know type [ __ ] put
down the big mac and the remote for a
second but anyways the point is this
is they always do this [ __ ] where they
project them their [ __ ] onto themselves
so they always say oh antifa they're
hiding behind they're hiding behind that
that name but they're actually fascist
it's they do that that's what they're
doing
like that's how they that's their modus
operandi so when they when they project
what their enemy is doing right
that is what they are doing that's their
modus operandi right is is to project
what they're doing on to their enemy
republicans and right-wingers that's all
they do like that's that's that's how
they work
usually it's it is extremism that has
that that radical
projection
so here's the guys saying
that they're going to denazify ukraine
while while supporting the [ __ ]
troops who are bombing a holocaust
memorial
in a country where the president is
[ __ ] jewish
a sovereign country
that the president is jewish a democracy
as imperfect as it is because ukraine is
definitely not anywhere close to a
perfect democracy
but
as the age of ukraine and the location
that ukraine is in and where ukraine and
what ukraine used to be
democracy is important there
and if it wasn't so important putin
wouldn't be bombing holocaust memorials
radio towers government buildings
apartment buildings
nurseries for [ __ ] sake let's listen
to this stupid piece of [ __ ]
these guys are tough these guys are
ready and there's plenty of them so so
in other words they they're weak they're
they're weak there's not that many of
them and they're not ready at all to
fight you catch that did you catch that
that's what he's saying they're [ __ ]
weak they're not ready to fight and
there isn't that many of them
russia
has used about 10 of its military power
so in other words there's only about 10
percent of its military power left
we're getting ready to bring the hammer
down
and the hammer has already been brought
there's no hammer left is what he's
saying these guys are gonna
save and liberate all the good people in
ukraine
they're going to save all they're going
to kill all the good people in ukraine
all the people who are pro-democracy who
voted for their president in their
democracy who want just to have their
lives and have their democracy so they
can have their liberty
and the bad people
and the bad people the bad people we're
going to make sure to prop those people
up you know the pro putin people that's
what we're going to do
he doesn't even look like he believes it
right
who is this [ __ ] guy who is this
[ __ ] gay
this [ __ ] guy
thanks for posting that video this this
buffoon um here's an article underneath
in this thread and there's also a
youtube video apparently this guy is
some kind of like local celebrity or
some [ __ ]
i don't know i don't know and i don't
know the legality of it like i don't
know the legals but it seems to me
it seems to me that some of this could
be considered treason to our country i
don't know i'm just saying
it's possible it seems that way okay
let's uh let's go back oh here is a
great video
uh from cpac i'm so glad i was down the
feed i might as touch put this out um of
course you know lee mcgowan politics
girl uh podcast she has a podcast should
be dropping today's tuesday i think her
podcast drops on tuesday um
let's listen to what she has says about
cpac because it's really important when
it comes to ukraine
it's really [ __ ] important and we
have to tie these bastards together we
have to tie all this together the
fascism that they want in this country
is the fascism they want and you that
putin wants in ukraine
why he's bombing holocaust memorials
dear republicans at cpac you are not
fighting tyranny you're selling
victimhood you paint yourselves as the
heroes of some mythical battle while the
world simply has to look at ukraine to
see what real heroes with real
patriotism look like citizens and
leaders fighting shoulder to shoulder
for their country its values and its
right to exist in the world well you're
busy selling t-shirts and bobble heads
and bejeweled purses in the ship of
glocks ukrainians were abandoning
everything they had to escape foreign
soldiers or actually arming themselves
to face an invading military and protect
the country they love
while your celebrity leaders are
frothing you up with fiery speeches of
imagined enemies and perceived slights
and pitching authoritarianism under the
guise of freedom the ukrainian leaders
are standing shoulder to shoulder with
their citizens facing certain death
ukraine is fighting a dictator who locks
up his political enemies the speakers on
your stage are suggesting we do just
that ukraine is fighting a country that
demonizes anyone who's not straight and
white and christian your party is
actively passing laws to do the same
thing
ukraine is fighting for their right to
free and fair election and to not be the
puppet regime of some brutal dictator
your party supports the dictator and
your leaders are his puppet
awake not woke that's the slogan of cpac
right then wake up you aren't the victim
or the hero of this story you are the
privileged and entitled spectators
talking about tyranny in a country that
has given you nothing but freedom
be honest with yourselves no real rights
have ever been taken from you you just
don't want to share those rights or
inconvenience yourself for other people
and that doesn't make you a patriot that
makes you an [ __ ]
so open your eyes we can see real
patriots fighting against real tyranny
in real time and you're still whining
about masks
grow up the adults of the world are
taking care of business while you
pretend cancer culture is a war
stop it enough is enough
you want to be a patriot support america
all of it not just the part you like
thank you lee thank you very much uh for
that video um um
and give us and the
lowdown on cpac and because this is what
they want they want they want what's uh
happening in ukraine they want the
republican party to do
what is happening ukraine i want to
search the uh
president zielinski here um
because someone sent me an article but i
want to see
what the deal is
someone is saying there's news saying
that possibly
there was uh um some forces that were
trying to assassinate him i'm just
making sure this is uh correct
i wanna verify
[Music]
looks like occupied democrats says here
breaking news ukrainian president
zlinski demands that putin and the
russia and russia be investigated for
war crimes and state terrorism over
their deadly attack on residential areas
the ukraine second largest city of
kharkiv
yes
also
the bombing
of the holocaust museum and the
government building
um let's see
that's the clip from earlier
all right um
here's here's the report from occupy
occupy democrats breaking news uh
ukrainian president zielinski announces
that the russian army has bombed
a holocaust memorial um which honors the
tens of thousands of ukrainian jews who
died at the hands of the nazis killing
five innocent civilians it looks like
that's the confirmation so far as five
innocent civilians
um
and all this to denatify right you know
denotify
ukraine by by bombing holocaust
memorials yeah okay
good
nice nice work
fantastic idea
really good idea and bombing [ __ ]
residential apartment towers get the
[ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ]
uh
and to do
let's see
um
this is some more of the statements
um
um zielinski seeks global ban on russia
at all airports and ports
so he's wanting a worldwide ban
on russian planes and ships
um so basically he's calling for the
entire world
to
put a moratorium on anything
to kill people um so he's he's not only
asking for them to shut down the economy
but shut down all imports and exports to
the country which is really going to put
pressure um not just on vladimir putin
but also the russian people and the
russian economy if they can't import
export anything um if they can't move
their money and if their money is worth
nothing
it really does put pressure on the
people of ukraine
um
let's see
um
christine it says when you dm me it says
you can't i'm not sure why
i have no idea i have no idea
uh tag me tag me in the post
just put at the tony michaels just tag
the post um it'll show up in my
notifications and then i'll try to
figure that out
and i'm not sure why i don't know
if you tag me in the post okay um and
that's a good way if you guys want to
show me a post and you can't dm me for
whatever reason um i get a lot of dms
too so sometimes i i
i can't find them all so um but if you
want if you want to just tag me on the
post you can do that either underneath
or do like a quote tweet and just tag me
there's a standing ovation i'm looking
to see
uh someone sent me an article i believe
it was mj sent it to me in my dm that
possibly um zelinski was
uh under attack
you're not following back me that could
be christina it could be if you just tag
me in a post or something i will follow
you and anyone else out there who i'm
not following on twitter that you want
me to follow just ask
i'll follow just ask
i will follow um
i don't mind handing out follows i i
don't i don't probably don't spend
enough time uh following back but if you
ask if you ask i try to find it and i
try to follow back so if you ask for me
to follow you back and i don't do it
right away uh ask again and i'll try to
get to it we're 48 minutes into the
second hour let's see if anything else
is trending here i can't find that putin
and nukes is trending um that's kind of
[ __ ] scary and then
uh let's see let's send the trendy
trends and tweety tweets here
uh see if anything else has gone up
of course uh
state of the union still at number two
um
looks like tucker carlson as a russian
asset has dropped off god damn it what's
wrong with you twitter
get it going here we got a joe mansion
still trending we gotta keep we gotta
keep the hashtag tucker carlson russian
asset
trending that's that's a good hashtag i
think i mean i'm all for that hashtag um
let's see let's go to putin and nukes
let's see what this is saying
announces the russian as well
okay um i'm trying to watch my
notifications as well
okay so putin and nukes um as you guys
remember um a must-read interview with
dr fiona hill
about putin's end game against the
panoramic historical backdrop remember
that hill who had knowledge of the
expertise to understand the current
threat is so clearly was significantly
targeted for removal by trump now you
guys remember who fiona hill was she
testified during the first impeachment
trial
um
nope that's not what i want
she testified during the first
impeachment trial
um
let's see
wasn't afraid of trump and she says in
this interview i believe let's go back
she says in this interview
that he most certainly she believes
fiona
hill believes
that vladimir putin
here it is victoria has it in a
wide-ranging interview
hill was asked if putin would use
nuclear weapons
hill says yes
he
would
yes he would in this interview
and it doesn't seem like she hesitates
at all
at all doesn't hesitate
which is uh disturbing
thank you victoria for
giving us that quote out of the article
it's a political article
go check that out what uh
dr hill has to say
about vladimir putin
and his nukes um it seems like that is
the thing that's trending is fiona hill
i'm saying that vladimir putin most
certainly would use nukes
um it makes sense and i don't know i
don't know that um that he would or not
you know
i don't know um i would hope that he
would see what the end result of him
using nuclear weapons would be i also
hope
that the world is on alert that they
wouldn't let it escalate to the point to
where vladimir putin was uh pushing the
nuclear button before he took a dirt nap
i'm just saying you know a long dirt nap
like a really long one like a permanent
one probably
um will biden is trending
will
biden
well this is uh
is is this the name is this the actual
name of hunter biden's laptop oh my god
i gotta i gotta tweet that
sorry i gotta tweet i gotta tweet live
tweet here
is
just saying will biden
saying
will biden is that hunter biden's
laptop's name um
see
bad company says i think we should
reserve
from asking what will biden say tonight
i would stay tuned and watch it will be
powerful i believe you bad company i
think you are correct in that assessment
i don't think um it probably is going to
be
very fluid in the uh in the way that the
stuff gets added in and takes out of
this speech
um as biden prepares to give the state
of the union in such a pivotal moment in
the world um it is very pivotal in that
we are turning corners with the
coronavirus in the world um and we are
turning corners now with the world
seeing putin for who he is because he's
definitely showing who he is and the
russian people
[Music]
okay uh let's see
so will biden is trending so go go get
um
um
go get on your will biden tweets
get on your will biting treats just
announced it's trending
yeah i'm gonna go there okay let's see
i appreciate you joining us for the show
today we're 54 minutes into the second
hour
now what a good show today with some of
these trends and in gabe joining us
talking about matt getz that's always
fun it's always fun to drag matt gatz
isn't it
i'm gonna really miss that guy once he
goes to federal prison for sex
trafficking aren't you i'm gonna miss
the guy i'm gonna miss i'm gonna miss
dragging on him
you know every now and again because he
will he you know he'll he'll go off to a
uh
a certain type of prison
uh for for sex traffickers
because in the federal system like you
don't go to you know if you're a sex
trafficker you don't go to like camp fed
right like you don't go to a cushy uh
prison camp you go to like a low or a
medium or you go to like a chomo prison
as they call it like you know that's
where all the sex offenders go is a
certain prison
so joel greenberg and matt gatz are not
going to have fun times
in federal prison uh once once that
happens so i i will i will miss dragging
on the guy he'll be where he needs to be
and probably not for long enough that
piece of [ __ ]
but you know i i will miss it i will
miss it so i'm hoping he does more
stupid uh boneheaded [ __ ] in the um
in the time leading up to that that way
we can drag on him a bit
same way with um lauren bobert and
marjory taylor green um did you hear too
that madison cawthorne
[Laughter]
madison cawthorne it doesn't it doesn't
appear that that guy's gonna be a
congressman much longer either he's
really pissed off too that there's laws
that prevent insurrectionists and
seditionists to um
to run in his state
it really does piss him off he really
wants to be a a nazi and run and run for
his uh his
his seat that he currently has but
um
and by run i really mean roll um i i
don't i don't call him this
i just have heard people call madison
conther in this um i've heard some
people call him sittler because i know
he loves hitler and you know
uh other reasons the [ __ ] madison
cawthorne [ __ ] that guy same way as [ __ ]
marjorie taylor green [ __ ] lauren bobert
paul goes-r the likes of him uh these
these the mo brooks
andrew clyde thomas massey chip roy you
[ __ ] pieces of [ __ ]
i'm surprised they weren't headlining at
f pack
the nick fuentes nazi rally
i appreciate you joining us here on the
show today i really do
i really do every single weekday noon
eastern 11 central tonight is the state
of the union uh don't forget to
go watch that and you can stream it on
the internet you can probably watch it
on your cable station or live on your
network stations
tune into the state of the union we will
be talking about that tomorrow i'm sure
we'll be breaking it down maybe maybe
we'll try to convince rachel bitkoffer
to come on and tell us what some of the
the state of union means what do you
guys think should we should we get
rachel on here to tell us what some of
that messaging means uh what the
president and break down what the
president says i'll maybe i'll try to
message her and see
if she'd like to come on tomorrow to
talk to us about the state of the union
and the follow-up of the state of the
union the other thing to watch is these
responses from the iowa uh governor as
she gonna ru as she as she attempts to
ruin her political career kim reynolds
which is good [ __ ] her [ __ ] her
good i hope she runs her political
career it's it's it's uh it's it's
political suicide to do the response uh
the state of the union for anyone and
you remember you remember the marco
rubio response you remember that we're
using the water
the water yeah dude you're done you're
done marco you're done
a slow political death that was with the
water bottles i that was that was a
follow-up to the standing i'm almost
pretty sure of it i'm almost pretty sure
of it
but we will we will see you tomorrow
here at the same time same place youtube
twitter twitch
uh follow us in all those places follow
at tony michael's pod
so that way that way you can participate
in the bonehead of the week poll we will
probably have that up tomorrow at toni
michael's pod follow me at the tony
michaels and follow co-host gabe sanchez
i am gabe sanchez
on twitter
instagrams
the tiki talks if you're over on ticky
tax do that there don't forget to um
subscribe to the youtube channel um
we're gonna have some great interviews
coming up we also have some really big
news um you guys are not gonna want to
miss out on this
so stay tuned uh stay subscribed
stay subscribed to the youtube channel
click the notifications click the like
button all that all the stuff that
you're supposed to do on the tubes of
you
also if you want to support the podcast
go over to thetonymichaels.com
uh you can buy some [ __ ] merch over
there i know if you guys want you a
[ __ ] hat or a [ __ ] shirt you can
buy some
[ __ ]
merch over there also i have gabe's
uh merch store up there too so support
gaby's got some cool stuff in his merch
store go to thetonymichaels.com
the link is in my bio
on twitter um and everywhere you can
just just go to the website
dtonimicals.com
you can find all those links all the
places to subscribe all the places to
follow
and really
until tomorrow because tomorrow's going
to be a big day i'm sure we'll have more
news out of ukraine and then we're going
to talk about the state of the union so
hopefully we'll have again hopefully we
can get rachel bitkoffer on here
to give us her analysis i'll try to i'll
try to twist her arm to get her on here
of course it doesn't take much to get
rachel on here she loves to come on and
talk to you guys so
maybe we'll get her on tomorrow
until tomorrow until tomorrow noon
eastern 11 central same time same place
youtube twitter twitch surfs up
[ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries
i think we've made that perfectly clear
we hope you enjoyed the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime follow tony
on social media at the tony michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking